well it is now Thursday by my calendar I
did not plan to lead the show on
Thursday talking about something that I
tweeted on Sunday in fact I didn't plan
to talk about it at all but it turns out
that what I tweeted on Sunday is very
big news one of the biggest news items
of the week in fact now this is not
according to me I don't find it
especially newsworthy to be honest but
rather it's according to the social
media mob and the news media and daytime
talk shows the post had me uh trending
for several days with thousands of
outraged people screaming various
unintelligible insults and telling me to
kill myself in various gruesome ways and
so on it was a subject of a lengthy and
angry think piece by NBC News another
one by Rolling Stone various other
articles by other outlets including the
National Review which called me out for
quote shaming it was also discussed
during a segment on The View and what
makes all this quite funny and ironic is
that everyone from the mob to NBC to
Rolling Stone to the ladies on the view
all agree that what I posted was stupid
because I shouldn't care so much about
the thing I posted about in fact the
subject of my post was so irrelevant
that they all decided to spend days
telling me how irrelevant it is
it's a rather common phenomenon in fact
so let's back up and uh tell the whole
story how did I become this week's super
villain what was the content of this
post the dumb post about a subject that
doesn't matter which is why it inspired
multiple news articles informing us of
how little it matters well it began with
a tick tock video published by a woman
named Julia mazor Julia has a tick tock
account where she frequently posts
videos about her life as a single and
childless 29 year old woman she also has
a podcast about the same subject where
NBC tells us she talks about being
pretty much done with the societal
expectation that she'll be married and
have kids by the age of 30. the podcast
is called pretty much done
so this is a woman who talks about this
subject quite a lot and talks about it
publicly which would lead you to the
conclusion that she wants people to
notice and hear what she's saying
typically if you have a social media
account and a podcast dedicated to
talking about your lifestyle choices
that's a good indication that you
consider your lifestyle choices to be
open for public discussion if you don't
want public discussion about the choices
you make in your life then the smartest
strategy would be to refrain from
speaking publicly and frequently about
the choices you make in your life and
even hosting a whole podcast on the
subject
now granted this woman had a relatively
small following up until now but I've
never heard of a burgeoning Tick-Tock
influencer and podcaster who only wants
a few thousand people to interact with
their content the point is that
when I saw one of her videos floating
around on Twitter I figured it's fair
game to respond to if this was a
secretly recorded video of Julia venting
to her friends in the privacy of her own
home taken and posted without her
knowledge then I certainly would not
respond or repost it I would never want
to participate in the invasion of
another person's privacy like that but I
don't consider a public response to
public comments to be an invasion of
privacy call me crazy
as for those public comments here is the
the video that started all of this
Ruckus let's watch
it's 10 45 a.m on a Saturday I'm 29 and
single and I don't have kids yet here's
what your Saturday morning looks like
when you're single at 29 and you don't
have a kid running around the house I
didn't rise from my bed until 10 15.
every time I thought I should probably
get up and do something I thought why
nobody's making me I'm not missing out
on anything I went to Beyonce last night
and I didn't get home until 1am and I
danced and drank my little heart out and
I didn't pay a babysitter to watch my
kids as I did that and I woke up a tad
hungover this morning which is probably
why I was in bed for so long and I was
just scrolling on my phone and I saw a
picture of Shaq Shuka and I thought you
know what sounds really good maybe I'm
gonna learn how to make shakshuka today
because I have no plans and I don't have
kids and I don't have a husband and I
don't have errands to run I can go to
the grocery store and learn how to make
shakshuka so that's on my agenda today
also on my agenda probably a re-watch of
some Real Housewives of New York I'm
also doing a re-watch of normal people
on Hulu which is really spicy and I
highly recommend weirdly I'm into this
documentary on Netflix about Blue Zone
countries so I've got a pretty stack day
anyway I say all this to say whenever
I'm hard on myself about why I'm not
married and I don't have kids and I
should be further along at 29 almost 30.
I wouldn't want to do anything else this
Saturday and I know that you can do all
these things when you have kids and
you're married and I understand but the
effortlessness and ease of my life just
kind of focusing on myself and the
shakshuk I want to make or the Beyonce
concert I want to go to really pays off
when I'm hard on myself for not being
aware Society tells me I should be in
life
okay all right so there's the the video
I responded to that video and I saw it
floating around by tweeting this her
life doesn't result doesn't revolve
around her family and kids so instead it
revolves around TV shows and pop stars
worst of all she's too stupid to realize
how depressing this is now I'll admit
the word stupid little harsh you know I
don't think it was a crime against
humanity I don't think it was worthy of
four days of intense intense National
outrage I don't think it was newsworthy
and I think by internet standards it's
like practically a high five I mean it
really doesn't uh it's not doesn't get
quite to the level of a lot of other
stuff you find on the internet but it
was a bit harsh but perhaps oblivious
would have been a more accurate
certainly more charitable choice of
words too oblivious
now I have been known I admit to use
harsh language at times I know this will
shock you if you listen to this podcast
so you say well you use hearth I never
heard it but I do sometimes and I will
tend to do that when I feel especially
passionate about an issue and I do quite
passionately oppose the promotion of
childlessness and the idea that we
should spend our young adulthood focused
on self-centered Pursuits and Mindless
amusements I I very much oppose that
idea I think it leads to Despair and
societal Decay I think that if a
critical mass of people adopt this
approach it eventually brings about the
collapse of human civilization
it's not to say that Julia on Tick Tock
will cause the collapse of civilization
but rather that the idea the life
philosophy
that she among many other people promote
if accepted by enough people will have
that effect which is why I tend to
attack this idea quite vigorously you
ever craved a nice barbecue meal with
your family say you go to the store get
all the groceries invite family over and
then you go to turn on the grill but
your propane tank is empty it's a
tragedy that's where cinch comes in to
save the day Essentials a propane grill
realtank Home Delivery Service they
deliver propane tanks right to your door
and on your schedule plus they don't
require any long-term commitment or
subscription delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to wait
around at home track the order on the
Cinch app from anywhere whether you're
grilling camping with your family
lighting up your fire pit on a cold
summer night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go online to cinch.com or
download their app to order new
customers can take get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Walsh that's Cyn ch.com promo code
Walsh this is a limited time offer and
you must live within a cinch service
area to redeem it visit cinch dot com
slash offer for details now that could
have been the end of the conversation it
was one tweet about one Tick Tock video
not a big deal
but then the outrage mob got to work and
they swarmed and they screamed and they
called me a bully and a Nazi and many
other things uh they they spent days I
mean days I was trending again for days
because of this
many other influencers including some
conservatives condemned me in no
uncertain terms random famous people
like Mark Cuban jumped onto the Dogpile
they said that she's just a young woman
having fun and I should butt out they
said that her choices are none of my
business
they blamed me for bringing attention to
Julia that they assumed she didn't want
which again is ironic because the whole
reason I was trending and that's why
Julia was trending by extension was
because it was because of all the people
outraged at me if they had all shut up
and gone about their day there wouldn't
have been any of this attention but then
again shutting up and going about their
day is not exactly the mo of the outrage
mop next came the media yesterday NBC
News published their article about this
now this makes I believe
my third NBC hit piece since July which
is a respectable pace of one per month
frankly I think we could pump those
numbers up and I'll try to do that but
the article has this headline quote
she was a child-free woman enjoying her
Saturday then came the culture Warriors
reading now it says Julia mazor was
having a relaxing Saturday when she
decided to Chronicle her day on Tick
Tock by Sunday she had become the most
recent fodder for the internet's ongoing
culture War about societal expectations
for women Missouri 29 had posted a 92
second video to her 7 000 Tick Tock
followers laying out a day in her life
as a single childless woman planning to
take a crack at making the egg dish
shakshuka and watch some TV the next day
the hate started to pour in quote all of
a sudden on Sunday I started receiving
hateful comments and then I caught wind
that he had posted my Tick Tock mazur
said he in this case is Matt Walsh a
conservative media provocateur who
posted mazor's video on X the platform I
know his Twitter two is more than 2.4
million followers stating that she is
too stupid to realize how depressing
this is other conservative pundits piled
on some on the left came to her defense
I think some the word sum is a perhaps a
bit of an understatement
um and actually I didn't post the video
on the platform someone else did but we
can't expect accuracy from NBC after all
I'm not going to hold them to that
impossible standard for them we're then
told this quote Missouri had
inadvertently found herself in an
ongoing and fervent corner of the
culture war that is increasingly playing
out online one where content that
directs hate towards women even against
women with relatively small social media
presences has become profitable and
popular inside and outside of
conservative circles Walsh and many
other right-leaning voices are part of a
larger conservative movement that
promotes what they consider to be
traditional family values that has
included targeting medical gender
transition procedures and openly uh
criticizing women who have not married
and had children one version of this
ideology has become known as Trad wife
content where women Envision 50 style
housewife ideals including subservience
to their husbands which has made the
practice controversial
now I'll say just another sidebar I
think the word inadvertent is doing a
lot of work there she quite advertently
has created a lot of content talking
about being quote Child free this is not
a conversation she finds herself in by
accident but the article continues NBC
News reviewed hateful comments made on X
about Missouri's appearance and her
ability to have children in the future
while mazur said she also received
direct hate and threats quote I
understand that with social media you're
putting yourself out there to be judged
or criticized but I don't believe anyone
has the right to spread hate and the way
his followers spoke about me and to me
was deplorable mazur said in a phone
interview it definitely gave me empathy
for celebrities and influencers who put
themselves out there painted a new light
for how the internet works
now a couple of quick things here uh I
don't believe that I was spreading hate
but whatever you want to call it I do
have the right to say what I said for
the record second
obviously if anyone is making threats
against this woman that is insane and
wrong and grotesque uh I will say that I
did not see a single person making
anything even resembling a threat and
it's interesting that NBC News reviewed
the quote hateful comments but they
didn't review the alleged threats
make that what you will from there the
article tells us how mazur wants to
wants people to ignore uh quote societal
pressure and quote live the lives they
want to live for themselves it says that
she rejected the quote rhetoric from her
first generation Russian Jewish Family
that uh the rhetoric that said that she
should get married and have kids and it
ends with this quote
I found myself in those safe good on
paper relationships but I also found
myself feeling deeply unhappy and
unfulfilled because I felt like I was
checking off a box to appease other
people throughout that process I
realized that's not the only thing that
can make you fulfilled I'm 29 and single
and I feel fulfilled by my life and my
career by my friends and my family
so she was in according to her good
relationships with good men which by the
way according to the information about
herself that she is volunteering to the
public
uh she was in good relationships with
good men she was uh these were good she
says they were safe
but she says she she left them anyway
because she was unfulfilled for
unspecified reasons and now she's 29 and
childless and focusing on spending her
time watching TV shows and so on what's
more she wants to encourage other people
to adopt this same strategy too as she
says live for themselves
now I must say again that I absolutely
reject
that I think it's terrible advice um I
think it's a terrible way to live and I
will never Tire of fighting back against
this despair-inducing philosophy no
matter who is promoting it
because the philosophy really is the
point here
it's the whole point okay it's not about
some woman on tick tock
and that's not what the left and the
media are concerned about they're not
angry at me for being mean to Julia
they're angry at me for attacking a
philosophy a philosophy of
self-centeredness and materialism that
they all personally live by
this was made clear in the Rolling Stone
article about this titled the right
would like all women to be 1950s
Housewives please apparently we've moved
on from transphobia for clicks to
shrieking at women for not giving birth
what follows from there is all the tribe
you would expect we probably don't need
to read through any of it we also don't
need to listen to Joy behar's take on
all this but uh as for that we actually
will listen to it anyway uh here it is
yeah Cuban now he uh he came to the
defense of a 29 year old woman who's on
Tick Tock uh extolling the joys of being
single and childless and it went viral
after conservative commentator Matt
Walsh whoever he is took issue with her
stance watch The Tick Tock here's what
your Saturday morning looks like when
you're single at 29 and you don't have a
kid running around the house I didn't
rise from my bed until 10 15. every time
I thought I should probably get up and
do something I thought why nobody's
making me I can go to the grocery store
and learn how to make shakshuka so
that's on my agenda today also on my
agenda probably a re-watch of some Real
Housewives of New York the
effortlessness and ease of my life just
kind of focusing on myself and the shack
shook I want to make or the Beyonce
concert I want to go to really pays off
when I'm hard on myself for not being
where Society tells me I should be in
life okay
[Applause]
in the get a life category this Matt
Walsh did a whole thing but my favorite
is that Stephen Miller the architect of
a family separation weighed in on this
about how children the most important
thing unless they're migrants I guess or
unless they're not his favorite type of
children Stephen Miller remember him yes
I do unfortunately and you know what
unfortunately he has two children
himself and I'm just saying that
well joy you don't have to act like
you've never heard of me we all know you
secretly listen to my podcast every day
just like I secretly watched The View
every day as Penance for my sins
um in any case it's obvious what's
really going on here the media and the
mob are pretending to White Knight for a
small time Tick-Tock influencer and
podcaster who suffered the horrific fate
of going viral which is the one thing
that every influencer and podcaster
dreads most of all but they don't
actually care about her as I said
they're not they're angry not that I
criticize what Julia said but that I
criticized them
she was expressing a point of view that
they all agree with and live by
and it's that point of view that they
are passionately defending it's the
point of view that says we should live
for ourselves focus on ourselves and
find happiness in our own pleasure and
amusement and that's it it's a point of
view that says the highest Joy is that
which can be found by consuming pop
culture content unencumbered by the
demands of family life and Parenthood
the point of view the one that places
living for yourself over living for
something greater and more enduring than
yourself
is the dominant view in our culture and
that is the point
that Julie on Tick Tock gets wrong most
of all
because she says that Society tells her
she should be married and have kids by
30. but that is not at all what society
says in fact the mainstream of society
the most powerful voices institutions
including corporate media fully agree
with her that young people should focus
on themselves and have fun and put off
marriage and family life
we know they agree with her which is why
she said what she said I disagreed and
everyone is defending her and attacking
me over that which is fine but it shows
that where does society land on this
pretty clearly on her end of the
spectrum
now
they agree that
you know even if we find ourselves in a
good relationship with a good person we
should leave it anyway in order to give
ourselves more time to scroll social
media and make shakshuka and whatever
else so between the two of us if anyone
is living in a way that is not approved
by society that is certainly not
recommended by society and is in fact in
many cases scorned by many in society it
would be me I'm 37 with six kids she's
29 with none the powers that be approve
of her choices much much more than they
approve of mine
she is already living as Society wants
her to live or at least as the Force's
driving Society want her to live
does those forces don't actually want
her or anyone else to be happy and
fulfilled
I do want that for her and for everyone
which is why I say yes you should get
married and have kids
I don't say that for my own sake I
already am okay so this is not advice I
need to give myself it's not something
that I benefit from
because but but it's something that
everyone almost everyone would benefit
from that is what most human beings on
this planet Are Meant to do to start
families
it's what we are called to do it's what
we are designed for
to form families to build homes to fill
those homes with love
and live in service to something greater
deeper and more beautiful than our TVs
and our phones and our careers
there's nothing wrong with any of those
things in proper proportion
but there's more to life
than that or at least there should be
and that's what I want the julias of the
world to understand
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed